[Musique]
petite vidéo de fin d'année 31 décembre
dernier jour de l'année ce soir
réveillon je sais pas si vous aller
réveillonner vous mais en tout cas je
l'espère
on va parler aujourd'hui lumière éclaire
a juste dit d'ailleurs en parlant
d'éclairage du studio on va tout de
suite changé
ce fonds qui est pas beau je l'aimé
toujours un peu plus foncée la gêne pas
trop comme sa voie la voie ferrée comme
ça moi je trouve ça mieux alors
aujourd'hui on va rajouter une nouvelle
langue
yoplait de philips ou le ce n'est pas
une vidéo sponsorisés je tiens à le dire
par contre je suis très content parce
que philips inclus dans son programme
d'influenceurs donc du matériel pour le
studio
c'est une très bonne chose je ne
comprends jamais comment sous ces trucs
on va regarder ça on va s'installer si
je trouve que j'ai trouvé comment ça
marche
[Musique]
ici c'est le secteur c'est pour le poser
suspense à la verticale posez pas à la
verticale à une vis là vous avez un
tronc là vous avez ça et là vous avez
une vie et une clé allen j'ai aussi un
trou en bas donc je peux aussi la fixer
comme ça en bas
[Musique]
doit pouvoir manger 3par prise secteur
oh
alors dans l'application ajouter des
lumières a ajouté une lumière recherché
recherche recherche un chef
yoplait est un nouveau jeu ajoute ceux
ci dessus elle criait tu es là je peux
le piloter comme l'ensemble du studio ce
qu'il faut savoir
avec le uplay si ce n'est pas uniquement
une lumière d'ambiance comme vous
pourriez avoir sur d'autres pas c'en est
une et mais pas uniquement vous pouvez
la mettre
d'ailleurs une télé et grâce à votre pc
ou grâce à votre mac ou ce que vous
voulez vous pouvez le synchroniser sur
du divertissement vous allez
prochainement votre télé nous regarder
directement sur votre mac
et c'est ça qui est cool parce que vous
allez voir une lumière qui va être
complètement adapté à ce que j'étais en
train de regarder
[Musique]
la première chose à faire vous devez
télécharger sur votre pc ou sur votre
mac
l'application qui s'appelle you 5 sur 6
de philips you là le téléchargement est
terminée on peut ouvrir problème you 5
est disponible sur mac / sirhan sirhan
mais pas sur mort avait pour l'instant
donc pas possible de l'utiliser
directement sur mon mac
néanmoins c'est que ce qui fonctionne
quelque chose qui existe déjà qui est
plutôt cool en plus ce qui est bien
c'est que vous peut créer des
environnements de loisirs pour du jeu
pour regarder des films pour tout ce que
vous voulez avec tout vos lumières
philips ou directement connecté il vous
suffit de créer un espace de loisirs
vous disposez vos éclairages dans votre
pièce de la manière dont vous le
souhaitez du coup ça permet d'avoir un
environnement maîtrisé vous mettez
autour de votre écran vous avez plus qu
avec du son camp se déroule dans un
endroit qui est complètement hyper
maîtriser enfin c'est vraiment cool
vous avez aussi toute une application
pour les dj lorsque vous mettez de la
musique pour que ça puisse synchronisée
en rythme donc ça c'est vraiment génial
il ya un troisième choqué super c'est
pour tous ceux qui possèdent du matériel
razer vous pouvez le faire avec la roma
ça marche c'est génial c'est cool c'est
pratique voilà c'est dommage mais vous
montrer directement sur mon mac
malheureusement avec mon avis ça ne
marche pas voilà probablement bientôt en
tout cas en tout cas est ce qui est cool
et je la trouve sympa très jolie sera
maître compléter ce que j'ai directement
au studio pourrait fixer différentes
manières et voyez le fait d'avoir le
double face là vous le prenez vous posez
la claque vous le fixer sur un mur
derrière une télé où vous voulez ce
temps est vraiment mal et customiser je
trouve ça vraiment cool voilà pour ce
matériel est aujourd'hui signé philip
sion permet d'agrémenter un petit peu le
studio va faire pas mal de choses qui
vont changer au studio pas mal de points
améliorer l'éclairage
déjà j'ai travaillé j'ai bien panneaux à
led la progression qu'elle allait
devenir pas mal d'autres choses encore
différentes qui vont arriver voilà bon
ça je garde tout ça pour
2019 on en reparle demain donc je vous
invite à me rejoindra dès demain pour
connaître un peu les objectifs de
l'allée savoir où on va d'ici là portez
vous bien vous révélions soyez sages et
à demain ciao